[Applause]
i'm a parent i've got four children two
of them are here
i want them to grow up in a country
where they can think what they want to
think
be what they want to be and not what
somebody's wife or somebody
in government makes them be i don't want
i don't want to have that what can
contemporary america learn from the late
rock legend frank zappa
who famously testified before congress
against record album warning labels
in the 1980s the parents music resource
center wants a labeling system frank
became the go-to person
because nobody else in the record
industry showed up
we live in a country where we're
supposed to be free we supposedly have
democracy
here what do we do sit around and go
he was on a mission and he was going to
accomplish that mission no matter what
as a new documentary about zappa makes
clear he leaves an ultra individualist
legacy that exemplified freedom of
expression
musical innovation and lifestyle
liberation
we were loud we were coarse and we were
strange
he had so much talent it despite
everything
by the time he died of prostate cancer
in 1993 at the age of 52
zappa had spent time in jail for making
an obscene recording at the behest of
undercover cops
released 60 albums in every genre
imaginable
and defended the sensibilities of
virtually
every american watch out
i think he matters now because he was
very far ahead of his time in terms of
dealing with where government was going
rise of far-right nationalism he was
very anti-authoritarian very
anti-fascist
and very pro-citizens rights um but he
also saw the tech revolution coming so
in all of these
extremely interesting ways zappa was
ahead of the curve
documentarian alex winter explored
zappa's commitment to free expression
throughout the film including when in
the 1980s
a group of senators wives formed the
parents music resource center or
pmrc and pushed for warning labels on
music with
lyrics they found offensive because of
sexual content
glorification of drug use and satanic
imagery
zappa emerged as one of the very few
rock musicians who pushed back
appearing before congress to defend free
expression
zappa's testimony is really really
impressive like it's basically a
a six-page manifesto about the
importance of the constitution
the pmrc proposal is an ill-conceived
piece of nonsense which fails to deliver
any real benefits to children
infringes the civil liberties of people
who are not children and promises to
keep the courts busy for years dealing
with the interpretational and
enforcement problems
inherent in the proposal's design it is
my understanding that in law
first amendment issues are decided with
a preference for the least restrictive
alternative
in this context the pmrc demands are the
equivalent of treating dandruff by
decapitation
it's interesting because in retrospect a
lot of people look at that those
hearings as a failure because they ended
up with the
the advisory sticker um
but the fact is is what the pmrc was
trying to do was censor
content uh at its root so to end up with
an advisory sticker which became
basically a badge of honor for any
artist
who wanted to appear legit um it was a
huge victory
and uh an enormous setback for this sort
of autocratic notion
of policing uh culture in in such a
ludicrous way
and uh and we find ourselves you know in
a similar time i'm sure zappo would have
been very vocal of what's going on now
but it did i think put him on the map in
terms of
a certain generation who may not have
come to him in the 70s or even
you know in the early 80s who suddenly
realized he was out there battling for
them he was very eloquent very
accessible
very smart and hilarious and he made
great music so i think it woke a lot of
people up to him
actually zappa's defense of
individualism and free speech had an
international audience too in 1990
vaclav havel the dissident playwright
who became the first president of
post-communist czechoslovakia
invited zappa to prague where he
received a hero's welcome
for inspiring resistance to
authoritarianism
there were thousands of people at the
airport they all knew who he was
he really was a symbol of freedom for
them
and he was very much a symbol of
of the western menace for the police
state
uh you know during the the communist era
which
helped him a lot at this time so uh
but i think that it was genuine i don't
think that like a lot of rock and roll
artists at that time they would just
spout sort of these kind of [ __ ]
cliches
about peace or about freedom and they
wouldn't really live it
and they didn't really mean it they
didn't really know anything um about
these things they really were just
capitalists who were
trying to get more more kids to buy
their records
um zappa really did i mean his album the
lyrics and his
he put his money where his mouth was and
i think that spoke to people as well
to winter zappa's appeal to americans
was similar to his appeal for people
living under communism
in societies that emphasize conformity
and decorum
he unapologetically blazed his own path
he didn't really fit into any particular
political bucket and a lot of people
claimed him
i think that zappa was at heart
anti-authoritarian
very pro-individual liberty he was not
super anti-government he just was
anti-government corruption
malfeasance and very pro-citizens rights